yo you bad [__] uncle Joey here
Thursday July 2nd wanted dead or alive
you understand me I'm here I came out
tonight listen I know it's the second
somebody is having on a time you gotta
put I'm not wearing a [__] mask this
is preposterous I'll take it to the
Supreme Court who gives a [__] what you
think
you're watching to my lord all the
episodes who gives the [__] about the
world right now
it's us we're gonna smoke the number I
got a [__] tremendous almond we sold
our soul for rock and roll what are you
[__] nuts or what we got lgbtq and the
[__] outfitters renting your nutsack
all that [__] well that little [__]
[__] [__] it's Thursday night we're
going deep [__]
Uncle Joe or anything I'm wasting your
[__] time with the other watch what
the [__] are you watching those aren't
the tiger ain't not not DV it's over
you've been sitting at home for four
months like a [__] tooth roots Uncle
Joe is here that's it we're gonna do a
couple tees just to [__] feel that I
got to join the debt what am i smoking
Kovac that's what I'm smoking I don't
give a [__]
we're going deep with taking some
edibles look I got everything here you
understand me I got a metal endo I got
Boogaloo pills
I got Kawasaki flu I got everything but
you don't meet dogs I'm a navy X type of
[__] but my tolerance has gone
up I can eat like four or 500 and these
[__] here they selling matter
they sell both of them at urban trees in
Studio City
you know I love my ABX my man Justin all
these [__]
but sometimes the time you got to mix
them up you know something you can't go
to Jupiter we make some nice you gotta
take a detour and go to [__] Mars so
let's start with these these are 25
milligrams each it's 250 [__]
milligram comes with a child safety lock
in case you're it if you're [__]
don't get these cuz you'll never open it
yeah I'm saying
like if you're stupid you're not gonna
[__] figure this out I'm stupid it
took me like a month I'd be sitting
around you gotta open these right here
oh yeah baby whoo Lord it and then you
got to squeeze and take this down like
this pop it out look at that two pieces
Oh Lord it now each tablet it's 25
milligrams there's [__] ten of them
in here and you know what's dog we don't
start there's no feeling period you ever
see two fighters like the first round
oh they're feeling each other [__] that
we don't feel nothing out here we're
gonna deal with all kind of them down
fairies wear boots [__]
tremendous album SATA bloody Sabbath I
think it says six studio album I don't
know the [__] year what do you want
what do you want from me maybe 74 73 I
don't [__] know tremendous it covers
Black Sabbath paranoid master reality
vol 4 and Sabbath bloody Sabbath you
know oh I think it also has sabotage on
here cuz I think wasp is I don't know I
don't know I don't have my glasses you
know me I come here I put the owl mine
and I get my head together speaking of
which what are you [__] nuts so what
we got it right here this is tremendous
this wheel you see you guys saying I got
two more boxes today set to mean it's
all over to shout it's Thursday night
happy fourth of July
[__] even Dean Cain got tortured
today you ain't the best Superman how
old are you you [__] who gives a [__]
about Superman if you smoking this [__]
that's Superman you know I'm saying [__]
you and your [__] Kate oh yeah look
at this [__] right here it's
beautiful people listen the rough time
is over uncle joey's yeah oh you having
a rough time it's the second the beaches
are closed it whatever Florida just
shoot yourself you guys are done
thousand cases you got there just gonna
switch your name - [__] the move man
yeah I'm saying
where you going this weekend whoo hat
bucket Texas I don't know what the
[__] going on down there but my boy
got covered I won't see you
[__] do you get your [__]
together and I rizona I don't know what
to tell you got to stay in the bucket
house you gotta stay in [__] it but hey
who gives a [__] you're smokin I scooped
you relax you're here with uncle Joey
yeah Florida you're done you won't see
me for years
Cubans are starting to swim back to Cuba
that's how bad things are oh yeah nice
what Thursday night here with you
[__] waiting on those smoke
signals I'm an Indian in about 8 minutes
you know I'm saying [__] the Redskins I
have the real [__] he had
Comanches the whole thing hmm
it's always very nice having you here
surprised I was sitting at home looking
at my family going I gotta get the [__]
out of here today
it wasn't my anniversary yesterday I was
home all day today the baby's off
tomorrow
she's got [__] no camp Saturday
people coming home we're gonna have a
little family little [__] thing so
the kids can play with masks on and
that's it man it's just another [__]
weekend whether it's covert or not
you're alive [__] what do you
need a little reef one friend and you
that's all you [__] me everybody else
could suck your dick
[Music]
little fairies with boot for you
[__] that I love it little plan
there there you go for you [__] the
covert [__] put that your [__]
eyeball there's drama going on
everywhere stay in mind your business
there was a fight over on Chandler a guy
with a knife on Chandler and Laurel
Canyon the woman with a shotgun in
Toluca Lake listen the crazies are out
if somebody don't have a mask on mind
your business like I'm getting over
don't say none to them cuz they might
pull out a star a deputy shoot you
I just seen a bi-racial couple walking
down the street people will beeping at
them people out of their [__] minds
don't pay attention don't cut nobody off
if somebody cuts you off let him go cuz
people got guns down you see the [__]
lady at Walmart she walked out bumped
into the black lady [__] the
african-american she pulled the gun on
her people crazy so mind your business
you don't know nothing as long as you
have a mask on you might know I don't
know nothing I don't know nothing I'm
just walking to my [__] car always
have your piece though always have it in
the [__] car ready to shoot him
[__] her leg and aim for the
camera shoot the camera shoot the
cameraman that's the first guy I'm
shooting no more cameras I take out my
gun I see you with a camera BAM you're
going down with and I take the phone and
I [__] sell it this I'm [__] poor
little guy over here but I haven't
bought coins actually [__] goes down at
the handball courts right here you want
to buy a 22 clean go to the handball
court they all fit whatever you want is
it the handball court I'm not gonna tell
you which one you got to figure out
yourself what the [__] not so what I
feel unhappy I feel so sad I've lost the
best friend that I ever had she was my
woman I love us all but it's too late
now
I
let her go I'm going through changes
what are you [__] nuts you guys
ignore with the Cuban burt bacharach and
tremendous song [__] changes
but hey talk is cheap you gotta walk the
[__] walk I love this oh oh yeah this
reefer is [__] I'm seeing [__]
people I'm seeing you [__] I'm
happy you [__] join this wanted dead
or alive
remember they can all suck your dick
there's no dentist prison that waabri's
the time go [__] yourself you ain't
getting dick it's all by you cover your
ass right now V's all you needs car
insurance and if it gets bad [__] the
car insurance people have people car
insurance all the time they're fine
saves a $69 step on it Bruno [__] the
general and [__] it all this [__] the
general I need the gel afterwards
insurance the [__] world it's a sure
it's an insurance company out of [__]
Turkey or something like that you try to
get paid from those [__]
they'll pay you're rubles we're gonna do
I still got the [__] just cuz
there's no stage I'm ready listen I miss
stand up like a [__] but before
I go and bother you people get covert
some when I'm in the [__] house I'm
[__] foaming at the mouth understand
me when I get this when I get on the
stage after I get offstage from now I'm
just gonna burn the [__] place down
it's over that's it
cela almost last time you spoke to Jimmy
you uncle you could have it because he's
locked up but uncle Joey's here hey
y'all uncle's all [__] up your
mother's brother he's out they stole the
car [__] him
don't send them dick he's a call every
day get me out this Kovac you should've
thought about that before you robbed the
contacts second aren't Kelly trying to
get outta jail on Kovac go [__] yourself
whoopee go B you won't get Kovac drink
water and keep being you [__] then I let
that [__] out they put them in
the cell next to that [__] English
chick the one that was hanging out with
funk and Einstein what's-his-name
epsteen epsteen Einstein who gives a
[__] jingling what's the name gisli that
poor [__] they got her under lock and
key they're gonna start [__] cutting
it down a Brit just Brent but I demand
my rights bright [__] bread you ain't
getting dick you will [__] setting up
[__] fourteen-year-old you [__] up
miss Ollie's everybody's going down this
week who gives a [__] what Dean Cain who
was the best Superman and I'm saying
well I gotta bother Dean Cain boy he
ain't bothered nobody he's just flying
around trying to be Superman I was a
long time ago
[__] don't worry about nothing [__] it
I'm saying we're going deep into the
murky waters
now all my days are filled with
tremendous this is listen if you ain't
in the [__] Sabbath we sold us so
just start there right now go on iTunes
get we sold our soul for rock'n'roll
forget about it and then call your
heroin dealers tell them we got a
Vikings you going to eat to that it's
over you're making the big leap into the
void you know I'm saying rocket ships
from burning fuel so fast before this
joint ends I won't let you [__]
know I love you you know that right I
got your back you got my back I'm with
you you're with me they wanna be with us
[__] them [__] maggots we're
running this [__]
it's Instagram live wanted dead or alive
with uncle Joey leaves in the corner
he's got Kovac [__] him I got him with a
ball in his mouth he's win for Eric to
come over put that fan in his [__]
you know I'm saying it's all over here
we go [__]
[Music]
here we go
a little [__] sweet leaf and that's
it it's over you know I love you
[__]
I just want to check in with you make
sure you're alright the church episodes
are up on YouTube Spotify wherever the
[__] you want they've got my beer I'm
like [__] [__] I'm everywhere I'm
saying this is the whole [__] meat
potatoes or the reefer this is what
these amateurs don't understand this is
the patois this is what makes you see
the devil
[Music]
are you kidding me I love you that's
[__] Savia right now
iTunes Sabbath bloody said no we sold
our soul my life was mp4 on ax down
oh [__] until you took me showed me
around
are you [__] nuts all right just
thing got too much CAC the [__] thing
climbs up
I sound like a deaf chick sucking a
[__] thank you mm-hmm [__] it
Thursday night [__] if you're
not gonna laugh go [__] yourself
there's no [__] laws against laughing
what laughing we don't give a [__]
listen we [__] push the line till we
hurt I don't give a [__] anymore who
gives a [__] 57 I got one foot in the
grave and one of your mother's [__]
at this point [__] I'm going in
[Music]
are you [__] nuts or what what what
there's no you mean I'm down to the
finger
[Music]
are we gonna do it that's it and that's
that I just want to join you let you
know I got your back let you know you're
not going through this alone whatever
the [__] you're going through if you're
depressed [__] go kick the homeless
do [__] it go get your Yaya's I'd do
something do what those
african-americans did till hit the
homeless guy with the firecracker up
there much as I didn't want to laugh
I had a laugh that's my sense of humor
you say I'm getting like a [__] mat
of firecrackers tomorrow I'll be
throwing some outside leaves whip down
the whole thing and I'm not racist I
don't buy my [__] firecrackers from a
Chinese guy I got a Filipino get him say
we don't [__] around he shows up with
firecrackers or the pigeon we're going
deep Wyatt Greg gives the page that I
got to write that one down
anyway man oh man oh man I love you oh
yeah party up baby all right
oh yeah
[Music]
right yeah yeah yeah tremendous people
I'm happy you joined me and I could go
home and sit there next to my wife and
make believe I give a [__] but I'm
watching TV oh that's interesting I
don't give a [__] I'm hi Tillie gills
I'm just yes some people at depth my
daughter's staying up late so I gotta go
home I gotta be quite [__] I look oh
here we go oh [__] oh [__] is that time
you bad [__] a little children
of the grave
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's the name of the song
that's it and that's that I love you
[__] alone my heart you know
I'm saying I'm happy you dropped by I
know you were [__] sitting there
thinking about [__] whether you
should pull a Brodie or jump off a
building but never fear
Uncle Joe is here yeah I'm saying I got
you [__] just when you think
don't I show up like [__] super duper
man you know I'm sayin so I love your
mother [__] this little children the
graves and show what what to do what
here we go here we go now it's cooking
you got the heroin put it on the spoon
it's a green light [__] all
systems are go before you shoot the
heroin drink some [__] water you
wanna be titrated you don't say you
don't want to go into an odd [__] all
[__] thirsty and [__] I've been there
not the nine but the other [__] anyway I
love your [__] with all my
heart
thank you for [__] dropping him
tonight
a little music remember we sold our soul
for rock'n'roll [__] classic we'll be
back this weekend I don't know what will
surprise you you might stay here all
night and [__] wake up at 6:00 the
morning you know how we wrote
[__] I love you stay black and
that's it what's the [__] you want from
me get your [__] together put your
[__] mask on [__]
put it on three hundred our fine on
nickel in Santa Monica
New Jersey New York you're fine just go
to Bayonne and smell that [__] in the
air you'll be fine if you haven't died
in New Jersey you ain't gonna die
don't worry about nothing I love you
[__] stay black I'll see you in
a few days
happy fourth of July all right we would
do the national anthem a flop all that
[__] we'll do it saturday a Sunday I
love you mother [__] this Lee honey turn
this thing off